- [Interviewer] All right, Chase.
Chase, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Originally I was born
out in Hawaii, actually.
I moved out here probably
at about five years old.
- [Interviewer] Oh really, which island?
- Big Island.
- Oh really?
- [Chase] Kialua-Kona.
Mom was from Alaska, you know,
got tired of the snow one
day, and just took off to.
- (interviewer speaking softly)
- Opposites, you know.
Met my dad out there, yeah.
So yeah, I grew up out
there for a little bit,
kinda remember some of it,
mainly like more pictures and whatnot.
But, you know, they
were still pretty racist
towards white people a lot.
- Oh absolutely, yeah.
- So my mom--
- [Interviewer] It's like
being black in Mississippi.
- Yeah, yeah.
My mom had a lot of trouble
finding work out there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So, I mean, after
about five years of that
she kind of got sick of it, and decided.
(interviewer speaking softly)
Yeah, moved to California. Oh,
so you've been out in Hawaii?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, (laughing)
I know what it's like to be
a black guy in the south.
- Oh yeah, haoles, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
They do not like that (mumbling).
I mean, it's a little
bit more calmed down now,
but back then they were
just, they were all over it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's very strange.
- Yeah, so once we moved out here,
pretty much the whole
family, or immediate family,
picked up, moved out here to California.
You know, that's all here and there,
but I grew up mainly out
in Santa Clarita, you know,
kind of, I guess, the suburbs.
- Yeah.
- You know.
Spent most of my high
school career out there,
like you know, doing the whole football,
sports thing, you know.
Had a lot of like rich
white friends, I guess,
you know which was kind of cool for a bit.
But that's how I kinda got,
I guess, introduced into
a lot of drugs, you know.
The party scene, this and that,
kind of spending like every moment I got
trying to hang out and get high.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Basically after that,
lost the house out there,
I somehow ended up out
in Lancaster with my mom.
That all ended up being kind of a burn.
I hated Lancaster.
There's so many,
just like there's just
nothing out there really.
- [Interviewer] Right,
you're right in the desert.
- So, at that time I was already
kind of addicted to heroin.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you'd found heroin.
- Yeah, I mean, I've been doing heroin
since I was 17 years old, you know.
I'm 30 now.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I'm actually not doing heroin anymore,
it's kind of advanced to fentanyl,
but we can get into
that a little bit later.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(sirens wailing)
- So when I got out to Lancaster,
and my means of supporting
myself as much were gone,
cause I used to grow and
sell pot for a few years.
I didn't have the clientele
anymore, out in Lancaster,
so I had to figure something else out.
So I picked up and moved
myself down to The Valley,
with a friend of mine,
and started basically selling heroin.
- Ooh.
- You know,
jumping around Airbnbs, you know,
for about month or two at a time,
you know, here, there, here, there,
and you're just like kinda selling drugs.
Basically,
met up with a girl down there,
ended up getting into a relationship,
and basically by the time I was 24,
close to being 25, she was about 30,
and we got arrested.
You know, I had already had a couple
little run ins with the law.
So like all of it was
basically possessions,
and whatnot, so I had a
little rap sheet of like,
you know, a drug user.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So when I got arrested for,
basically she got arrested,
and got caught up by selling
to an undercover, you know,
so it was all her doing, I was just there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And by basically meeting
up with our drug dealer,
and then her middlemaning a sack,
because there was three parties involved
they were allowed to charge
us with conspiracy of sales.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- You know, luckily they only charged me
with about six months, I had
to do flat time, you know,
and I had to six months in jail,
it was probably the longest stint
I've ever had to do in jail.
Just a couple like
before that a month here,
maybe a couple of days, a week, you know,
but I'd always get out.
But this time was six
months, and I was just
going to be that's it, six
months, no time off, nothing.
And basically,
was still with the girl.
She only got off with
about a couple of days,
maybe a week, time served,
because it was the first
time she ever got caught
doing anything like that.
First time she ever got caught
doing anything, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- So the judge kind of
just let her off easy.
Me, I had the little rap
sheet I was telling you about,
so they were saying,
"Okay, well, you know,
"you didn't really do
anything, but at the same time
"you're looking more
guilty than you seem."
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- So threw the book at me,
and they gave me as
much time as they could,
which happened to be six months,
which wasn't too, too gnarly or anything.
But, you know, once you get to about
like a couple of months in there,
you kind of get a little stir crazy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But did that, and got out.
So I decided to get back out
to Lancaster with my mom.
Figured, okay maybe I can do this,
and like I had already
gotten clean in jail,
pretty much, was just like,
"Okay, I can handle the Lancaster thing,
"nobody around, just whatever."
Well the girl was still around,
so immediately after I got out,
I was back into drugs, you know.
- Started using again.
- Yep.
And a few months later, that's actually
when I got into my motorcycle accident,
and basically lost my hand.
I was in the hospital for about a week,
because I was all on Medi-Cal,
so like they didn't really.
- [Interviewer] Did you realize that
you were going to lose
your hand right away?
Or, how bad was the accident?
- That actually is a funny,
like kind of little thing
that I always think about, too.
Cause basically when it
happened, I'd seen it all,
I was conscious.
So like my hand was pretty
much severed, you know,
barely hanging on by a ligament or two.
And I mean, I'm talking
about artery was cut,
like I'm bleeding in a pool of blood.
- [Interviewer] What was connected?
- Just maybe a flap of skin,
and like the ligament that connects
my thumb and my next finger,
like I could barely do
that, and that only.
- [Interviewer] And the rest of your hand
was just hanging off?
- Yeah, it was just hanging there.
Just could not, I couldn't
feel it cause I was in shock.
You know, I just flew 30
yards in the like, you know,
in the air, and tumbled.
Actually on my way to go pick up a sack,
you know, funny enough.
And basically they took
me to the hospital,
and they kind of shoved me
out as fast as they could,
cause I was, you know, on Medi-Cal.
Shipped me off to San Bernardino,
which actually had a
physical therapy rehab
that I stayed in about three weeks,
about four weeks, or something like that,
cause I mean, I just
wanted to get out of there.
Cause not only was the,
I wasn't really dope sick,
you know, from not having any dope,
cause they had me on Percocets.
And while I was in the hospital
they had me on Dilaudid and stuff,
but I had like the whole mental issue
of everything, you know.
The depression was kicking in, you know.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- You know, and like
all that restlessness,
and I'm broken kneecap,
severed hand, like, you know,
I was pretty messed up,
so like I couldn't really walk around.
I was in a wheelchair,
and I had to have assistance
getting out of bed,
into a wheelchair, like, you know.
So that restlessness was
killing me, you know,
I was just stuck in a bed, you know.
Nobody that I knew was around me,
so the depression just
got crazier, and crazier,
and I was just like, "I
need to get out of here."
So I mean, I pushed to, basically,
get out of there as fast as I could.
And I'm talking, I didn't even get home,
like, when I got out of
there it was July 4th,
2015, I think?
Maybe 2014.
July 4th, and I didn't even get home yet.
I had my mom stop off somewhere
where I knew I could pick up,
I called my drug dealer from the rehab.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- I was like, "Hey",
you know, "What's up?"
And he said "Where you been at man?
"Like what happened that day
"you were supposed to
come and get that sack?"
And I was like, "You'll never guess, bro,
"I got in a fucking bad
motorcycle accident,
"I've been in the hospital, you know,
"but hey, I don't got cash,
"I have my EBT card on me.
"Let's work something out."
Like, you know, before I even got home,
I had my mom stop off somewhere
that I knew I could meet him.
And I got a sack already,
and I was back on it already.
So I mean I'm downing Percocets,
you know, back at home.
They were giving me Ambien
to go to sleep and shit,
and I was taking them like candy.
And that kinda like went
on for a little bit,
And I kind of was using the the accident
to maybe kinda squeeze some money
out of my mom at the time, you know?
Cause I was telling her that, you know,
I ran out of my prescription, you know,
and we tried getting another, basically,
going to I think a clinic,
or I forgot how we were
trying to get another prescription for me.
But, you know, basically,
cause I had ran through
the original ones too fast,
you know, I couldn't fill the new one.
You know, so I wasn't
able to get it filled,
and I was like, "Oh, how
are we going to do this?"
So I started telling my mom like,
"Oh, well I know somebody
who's got these pills.
"Like, you know, I can go
pick up some off of them."
So that became like the
new daily, like, you know,
I wasn't even having
to trade pills anymore,
I was just getting money
to do this and that.
And basically just
waiting for my settlement
to come through, you know,
cause of the accident,
you know, it wasn't my fault at all.
A car didn't see me,
and they turned out right in front of me,
and I belt up right into it, you know,
and I was going about 80 miles an hour.
So, yeah, getting pills.
I was telling my mom I
was getting the pills,
but I was using it for heroin, obviously.
You know, because I mean,
I don't know if you know too much
about like chemical dependency,
and like, you know, heroin,
but once you get to that
point of an opiate, you know,
lesser ones don't work, obviously.
You know, so I can sit there all day long
and take as many like pills as I want,
but because of the heroin,
it's not going to do too much.
You know, so obviously I was
spending the money on heroin,
and basically at that point just waiting
for my cash settlement to
come through, you know.
I had a lawsuit going with basically
the driver's insurance, you know,
just kind of, you know,
trying to get money
to just take care of myself
for a little bit, you know,
which obviously didn't work out that well.
It went through, you
know, I got my settlement.
Because I didn't actually
have active insurance
on my motorcycle at the time,
it kind of fucked me pretty bad,
and I was only able to
get like a hundred grand
out of the accident.
Which, 30 of it, 30,000 went
to my attorney at the time.
- [Interviewer] Oh, yeah.
- And because I was on Medi-Cal,
I don't know if you know
too much about Medi-Cal,
and how they do all that bullshit,
but I had to pay back
some of my medical bills,
which was up to about $24,000
I had to pay for that.
So, I mean, I got
50 or so, you know,
50 some, $56,000 from that.
- [Interviewer] You lost
a hand and got $50,000.
- Yeah, you know.
And a lot of people were kinda
"Oh yeah, I'd do that in a heartbeat,"
but a lot of people don't really realize
like what comes with that, you know.
Like I was right-handed when
this happened, you know,
obviously, you know I'm left-handed now.
I used to be a little bit ambidextrous,
you know, when I was
back in my stoner days
I thought like it was funny
to do shit left-handed,
so I mean, I write better
now with my left hand
than I ever did with my right.
- [Interviewer] Oh, interesting.
- Yeah, so,
I spent a lot of time
trying to do that though, too, you know.
- [Interviewer] What have you been doing
since the bike accident?
- (lips blowing) Shit, I bought a house,
or I started renting,
or I started mortgaging
a house, basically.
My mom moved out with her boyfriend,
so I took over the lease on that house.
And slowly but surely that house
became a trap house in
Lancaster, pretty much.
(laughing) I mean, there was so many drugs
going in and out of it,
and my friends were just
like staying here and there.
Girlfriend at the time was living with me,
and just, it went fast, you know.
All the drugs, and you know,
I was getting probably
$7,000 every two weeks
on checks from my attornies.
And I mean, I'm talking by
the two weeks was coming up,
I was already waiting for that
next check to come through.
(laughing)
And I mean, a lot of
people don't really realize
how fast you can spend money.
- Yeah.
- But it goes man.
But ever since then,
like as soon as I kind of lost that house,
that's when, I guess, a stint of like
kind of my second or third
round of being homeless
kind of started, you know.
When I was living in in the Valley,
you know, selling heroin,
my money, me and my friends money
kind of ran out, and the
Airbnbs kind of stopped.
So basically we started living in the car,
or I started living with
my girlfriend, in her car,
You know, we were renting U-Hauls,
kind of sleeping in those
for a bit, you know.
So I was already kind of used to,
you know, sleeping outside.
The drugs helped, you know,
it wasn't like I was dealing
with too much outside.
It was like, okay, I'm
nodding off here or there,
it wasn't that bad.
But Lancaster, the weather
is just so extreme, bro.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's cold at night.
- Yeah, cold as hell at night.
And this time it was just
about to be winter time,
or winter time was just ending,
so I was freezing my ass off out there.
And as soon as basically summertime
started to roll around,
me and the girlfriend were trying
to basically get sober, in a sense.
You know, trying do it
together, that whole deal.
So I came out to my sister's
house, down over here,
or at my sister's apartment,
off the Expo Line, actually.
She used to live off the
Los Cienega, in Jefferson.
It was a pretty nice area, you know,
and our plan was like,
you know, get sober,
and then we'll figure it
out, go to rehab, you know,
do that or, you know,
figure something else out.
So we're out here for about a week,
and you know, medically, you know,
we did it with like Suboxone
and Subutex, like, you know,
so it was pretty clean, it wasn't too bad,
you know, except for the
mental part of everything.
And just about when that
week started ending up,
you know, she got a little restless,
and basically made up an
excuse to kind of turn up
back out in Lancaster.
And being the idiot I am, you know,
I followed her, and went back out there,
and started using again, you know.
So, after that I got sucked back out
in Lancaster, and was doing
the whole homeless thing,
kind of like stopping
by my moms, you know,
like "Can I sleep in your car?
"It's cold out here,
let me charge my phone",
like all that bullshit, you know.
Just realizing how like slowly
I'm fucking killing my mom
with all this bullshit.
And I never tried to
ask to stay at her place
with her boyfriend,
because her boyfriend was
an ex-addict, you know,
he used to do, I think, crack,
and you know, basically
was drinking a lot.
So I wasn't trying to bring my problems
over to his house, you know?
Cause I felt like I might lead
him to relapse or something.
I know how all that bullshit works.
- [Interviewer] Right.
So I never asked, I was like,
you know, "I'll stop by,
"like I'm not gonna not
going to try and be here,
"and use, or anything like
that around you guys."
So I just stayed out, you know,
wandering around, and hanging out,
staying with friends here and there.
And she was getting pretty tired of it.
So I mean, at that point I was like,
"All right, well let's try and get sober.
"Let's go do something to do this."
So I got myself into acting rehab,
out there, right before
Palmdale, on like the 14.
I made it about two days,
cause they don't actually detox you there,
they want you to be
clean before you show up.
(interviewer speaking softly)
- Yeah, so I went in there with fake piss,
and some drugs, trying to just,
"Okay, I'm gonna wean
myself off, and stay here,"
and work it out that way.
Well, somebody ended up
saying something, or whatever,
and you know, I got busted
after like two or three days being there,
and got kicked out.
Which I didn't really care,
I was like, "Whatever, I'm
going to call my girlfriend.
"figure something else out."
After a couple of weeks,
or a couple of months,
of just like doing the
whole homeless thing again,
were basically my mom
called me and told me that
"I got you a place to
go, and detox, on Monday,
"so show up, or not, but that's all you."
So I partied my ass off
that weekend, you know,
I had some drugs left over,
and I went and detoxed
down in Pomona at A-R-C,
ended up staying there,
detoxed there for about a week,
and moved to the program downstairs.
And complete, successfully
did it for about three months,
you know, I was clean, and I was planning
with my counselor there,
staying there for four months.
But just about when the three
month mark started coming up,
he takes me aside and tells me
that basically your
application for, you know,
another month here didn't go through,
and, you mean, you got two
days left to hit 90 days,
and you're going to get
kicked out, basically.
You know, I have no plan at this point,
you know, I'm just like back at step one,
"Like oh, fuck, like
what am I going to do?"
And I panicked, and relapsed, you know,
and then ended up getting
kicked out of the program.
Basically, I was tired of
telling my mom that, you know,
I'm doing drugs, all this and that,
so I couldn't call her anymore.
It was breaking my heart just to like
try and tell her these
stories, like you know,
asking for money, or anything like that.
So I was like, kind of
at that point decided,
well, you know, if I'm going to use,
I might as well just go somewhere
where it's kind of familiar,
and I can kind of get away
with just being homeless.
So I came down to Skid Row, you know.
Luckily, I kind of, the month prior,
ran into somebody I knew down here.
I actually, coincidentally,
used to sell him drugs
out in Lancaster, and I
ran into him down here,
and so that's the first person I called.
I told him, like "Hey, bro,
"I just got kicked out
of my sister's house,
"I'm going to come down to Skid Row,
"can you help me set up a tent somewhere?
"Like, do you know any like
safe spot, like you know."
Basically came down here one night,
spent that night in
his friend's apartment,
and the next morning shipped
off to set up a tent, you know?
That actually, coincidentally,
it was just down the road right over here.
I've actually been down over here
in this little area for about a year now,
pretty much just doing it,
you know, just kind of
hustling up where I can.
I partially,
I don't know if you've ran into people
telling you about
boosting, or anything like.
- Yeah.
- But I mean, yeah, yeah.
So, I mean, I don't like to
be referred to it as that,
I mean, I kind of tell people sometimes
I'm in product redistribution.
(interviewer laughing)
So I mean, you know, it's
quite lucrative, you know,
some of these prices down here, you know,
down here in MacArthur Park.
But, you know, if you know what they want,
and you can get away with
getting enough of it, you know,
you can buy the world
these days, you know.
But pretty much just I've been doing that,
selling drugs, you know.
I've had a couple offers
to be selling myself
but I just can not do that, you know.
And it's all from men,
too, and I'm not gay.
So it's just like, "No."
(interviewer speaking softly)
- Yeah, you know, yeah.
You would you be surprised, sometimes,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
But that just.
Honestly,
a lot of people tell
stories about how bad it is
down here, and this and that,
but you know, I'm one of those people
that kind of just like,
I look on the brighter
sides of everything.
And like, honestly,
it's been bad out here,
like I've been pistol-whipped,
I've been fucking gashed
on my head, like you know,
and that's like the worst thing
that's ever happened to me down here.
And that's all due to something I did,
there was nothing on just like accident,
like that's just
something I did, you know,
being a dumb drug addict, you know.
And like, you know,
I faced it, and I had to handle it.
But you know, it's not that bad,
as long as you can kind
of surround yourself
with people who, you know,
at the time I guess care,
but just seem to care about you, you know?
Cause when it comes down to it,
all of these people do
care about themselves.
And if you can kind of learn
to just take care of yourself,
it's not too bad.
You know, I've kind of gotten my niche,
and kinda gotten just points
where I can take care of myself,
or surround with people that
actually like, you know,
take care of me, and I take care of them.
So you know, it hasn't
been too rough of a year.
But, you know, this is only
my first year, you know,
and I haven't had to do it too long.
But, you know, it is
getting tiring, you know.
That is one thing I will say, you know,
it is tiring having to
just do the same thing
over and over again you know.
I haven't been arrested.
Oh, actually I take that back,
I've been arrested out here
once, for fucking warrants.
You know, I had to go
to jail, just in July,
like right after my birthday, actually.
My 30th birthday, I got arrested,
like a day or two, you know,
I was in jail because of old warrants
that I thought were taken
care of but weren't,
and you know, that's about it.
And been lucky enough not to get arrested
for shoplifting, or crap like that,
or, you know, possession of drugs.
But you know, it's been
okay I guess, you know,
I'm not too, too battered from
the whole experience I guess,
but you know, it kind of just,
you know, I'm still going.
You know, I'm kinda still
just rolling through it all.
- [Interviewer] Chase, thank
you for telling your story.
- Yeah, of course.
- [Interviewer] Very interesting,
good luck with everything.
- Oh, thank you.